- [Narrator] Of the 30
major league Baseball teams,
26 have infield mixes sourced from here.
- All right, so this is what we're after,
the beginnings of a Baseball field.
All the hard work, crushing
rock, all for this right here.
- [Narrator] This right
here is Pittsburgh red bed.
And this clay stone is unique
in how it reacts to
one key element, water.
- For the owners of the teams,
it's about playing in the rain.
You equate it to monetizing
what the cost of the infield was
versus playing a game in the rain.
- Water's very important
because it absorbs the ball
bounce, almost like corkboard.
- [Narrator] But just getting to the clay
can take two months.
Here's how a single dirt
farm takes all of this,
to turn into this.
It all starts here, 300 million years ago,
sediment from eroding mountains deposited
this unique rock unit called
the Glenshaw formation
and the Pittsburgh red
bed is hidden within it.
- [Grant] We have to remove
all of the overburden above it,
the sandstone, the gray shale
and then a limestone layer
that's about a foot thick
at the bottom.
- [Narrator] The
overburden becomes thicker
at higher elevations.
So DuraEdge products can
only mine for the clay here.
Otherwise...
- It's cost prohibitive to mine the clay
because you have too much
overburden to take off the top,
it costs too much money.
- [Narrator] Pittsburgh red
bed is predominantly made up
of illite and kaolinite, two clay minerals
that can absorb water without swelling
and dissipate the water quickly.
- As you can see, this
material is very densely packed
so we have to take it up to the plant
and crush it to make it a usable product
for Baseball fields.
- [Narrator] Over the course of a year,
excavators will mine and then
load approximately 30,000 tons
of the clay into these trucks
driving it all to a processing
facility an hour away.
- The challenge to this
business is taking something
that's this hard compressed in the ground
and then ultimately we wanna
get it into that powder.
We wanna mill it into
something like talcum powder.
- The clay is pre
crushed with a bulldozer,
then reduced down to an inch and a half
thanks to this bucket.
- [Grant] It's got hammers on the inside
and teeth that grab the clay
and physically smash it.
- [Narrator] Finally, the
clay is pushed through
a REMco crusher.
- It's a vertical shaft
impact crusher, and it spins
at 1800 RPMs.
Between that bucket and that crusher,
it's made the product
perform so much better.
- But transforming the
clay into infield mix
requires a specific proportion
of clay, silt, and sand.
- The sand creates void space.
The silt and clay fill the void space
when it's in the proper ratio,
and that requires the use
of a pug mill, which
is back here behind us.
So what happens when you
put it through the pug mill?
You build friction inside the mixer
and when you grind the
two products together
the clay will actually
adhere into the sand
and it comes out as one
single homogenous mix.
- [Narrator] The company
creates three types
of infield mix that vary in proportions.
Professional grade
infield mix has less sand
and more clay content, which
helps retain moisture better
but also requires more maintenance.
- This is a finished product.
Once you smooth it off,
you can tell if there's anything in there.
If the sand's too fine,
I can tell it won't hold
together quite as well.
If the sand's too coarse,
the coarse particles will stick out.
When I'm testing my product
and I've got the right moisture in it
and I can go like this with my
product, it'll stay together.
You could almost juggle.
I don't know how to juggle,
but you could juggle
these balls, right?
But then when I drop it on the ground
I want that ball to just
completely fall apart.
So then I'll go like this
and I'll pack it down
and ultimately when it's compressed
that's what the surface
is gonna look like.
- [Narrator] Stadiums nearby
will have their infield mix
delivered from the main
processing facility.
For stadiums farther away,
only the clay is shipped
and the infield mix is made
at one of DuraEdge's satellite locations
saving up to 70% in freight costs.
- It cuts down tremendously
on logistics costs
because if you were to
make it all here in ship it
to Salt Lake City, you would
be shipping five more trucks
and the cost of that would be too great.
There are some groundskeepers
that want things
made slightly different, but by and large,
we're producing the exact
same product for every team.
- Like at Citi Field...
- Citi Field infield mix
is actually very similar
to a lot of the other ballparks.
Sometimes regionally they differ slightly
just based on the weather.
That's a big factor for us here
is how our infield mix performs
in different weather conditions,
Hot humid, dry, wet rainy.
You know, we're trying to
get it the same every day.
- [Narrator] Building a
major league baseball infield
from scratch requires up
to 350 tons of infield mix
which can cost anywhere
from $50,000 to $80,000.
So many stadiums focus on maintenance,
incorporating smaller deliveries
into their existing infield as needed.
- What's gonna happen
after he's done scarifying
is we're gonna add a
little bit of material
and the laser grade's
gonna push the material
into all the little low spots
and cut from the high spots
so that everything's nice and level.
He is actually finishing the grade
of the infield to within
about an eighth of an inch.
- Infield are required to be graded
so that the baselines and
the home plates are level.
Then a thin layer of top dressing
or conditioner is added
to help retain moisture
and enhance the sliding
surface for players.
- So this machine right
here is the final step.
This is a one and a half ton roller
and this will pack everything back down
when we're done laser grading.
After that, a little bit of
water and we're good to go.
- [Narrator] The trick is to
keep the infield consistent
every single game.
- When an infield mix isn't
good, it'll break apart.
So as players are running around it,
chunks will be coming out of
it or something's acting up
then we'll check moisture meter
and we have a range that we like to get.
It's gonna play well in that range.
- [Narrator] But roundskeepers
can often check the moisture
with one simple trick.
- If the key goes in and
out nice and smoothly
then we know that it's
where it needs to be.
So the key goes in, it
has a little bit of force
and then it comes out
and there's no chunks.
It's nice and clean.
Water's very important for an infield
because it absorbs the ball bounce.
It makes the infield mix pliable
and almost like corkboard
- [Narrator] Before soil science
became standard application
in the MLB ballparks, teams
relied on local suppliers.
But groundskeepers say infield
dirt then was inconsistent
and more difficult to maintain.
Competing infield mix
suppliers say their products
achieved the same purpose
without using the specific clay.
But after starting with the
Philadelphia Phillies in 2005,
DuraEdge product supplies
most MLB teams today.
- It started to get out a
bit more around this part
of the country that, you
know, I'm the dirt guy.
People are incredibly
surprised by the fact
that this is where it comes from.
And Presto, whamo, you got infield mix.
That's how it works.